hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen endlich mal wieder
zu einer neuen zieht vorstellung also
wenn ihr nicht wisst dass einzieht ist
muss man ja mal so ein bisschen erklären
das ist eine sache die muss ich erkennen
oder also seid ihr könnt wenn ihr eine
welt generiert einfach einen code
eingeben und dann bekommt in eine welt
die eventuell wenn im gleichen ort
eingeht wie ein anderer wird es die
gleiche welt sein wie zb ein freund hat
wenn der freund in loop eingibt dann
bekommt ihr auch die welt namens luke
und na ja also das hier bin ich ich
hatte eine menge probleme im hintergrund
fast alles zu entdecken gibt da will ich
gar nicht so hoch gehen eigentlich ist
ja gerade 19 uhr und es kommt jetzt
eigentlich auch feed the beast sache ist
dass simon und ich wahrscheinlich von
der wolf 20 was unser jetziges pages of
mind crack umsteigen werden
das machen auch ein paar amerikanische
youtuber kette mit sicherheit ist so wie
der wolf 20 hat nur glaube ich 34 muss
weniger drin oder mehr ich weiß es gar
nicht genug mal ganz hinten baum ganz
alleine da ganz oben
die jetzt direkt auf meinem kopf sitzen
baum naja jedenfalls steigen wieder um
und versuchen gerade den mori teils der
zu kontaktieren ich wollte schon
attackieren sagen wir versuchen ihn zu
kontaktieren dass wir uns auf einen
server aufsetzt und lieber erstmal wurf
20 drin wären wahrscheinlich morgen auf
dem das dann sonntag oder montag die
nächste folge kommt weil wir auch
allgemeinen letzter zeit nicht hochladen
können weil simon ja bei seiner freundin
ist mit der der internet hat das ist
sein buch leitung die geht irgendwo
durch den dschungel da noch mal 1000
katzen herum und dann reißt sie alle
drei minuten ab und na ja ich würde
sagen wir fangen erst mal mit dieser
steve vorstellung jetzt einfach die ich
mal sollte ein ausgleich benutzer weil
es ja auch schon öfters keine
vorstellung mehr gegeben hat ich habe
die welt jetzt dreimal generiert einmal
bin ich hier gespannt
also jetzt gerade einmal bin ich hier
unten gespannt da im wasser und einmal
bin ich auch hier gespannt und das war
man erst dass bonn und dann bin ich habe
ich das hier entdeckt und den sieg habe
ich echt selber entdeckt also hier ist
der sieht der sieht es 65 42 72 98 96 15
07 91 41 90 eine telefonnummer
erst mal was ich sehr cool findet ein
gemeinden diese landschaft darum sind
zwei bäume können man perfekt gegen eine
brücke durch bauen
ich gebe dann oft ein paar tipps was man
machen könnte ich selber bin nicht so
gute bauer hier und ist auch so eine
fette schluss da kann ich einfach mal
runter ich bin hier und ich befinde mich
wenn ich ganz am boden bin
auf höhe 63 also auf wasserhöhe
normalerweise und wenn ich dann wieder
hier oben bin hier damit ich hier auf
höhe 101 also 40 blöcke höhenunterschied
hier ist ein lava sie übrigens das habe
ich noch gar nicht entdeckt der
sechziger hat alles in brand
das wird auf jeden fall okay der
dschungel wird nicht lange halten denke
ich aber das wusste ich gar nicht
das sehr traurig ihr haltet dem standen
ihr haltet dem stand ihr schaftler
setzlinge geschafft ihr job
also da ist um nach oben ist dass ich
gar nicht gesehen das tut mit leid
naja egal aber ich wollte ich das hier
zeigen weil so eine landschaft kann
natürlich nicht abbringen
also ich bin hier gespannt hier kann man
übrigens auch durch und jetzt also ein
kleiner see der ist nicht auf 64 erhöhen
doch besser doch der ist auf 64 erhöhen
allerdings finde ich das ist eine
richtig geile lagune sowie die goulagou
das spongebob finde ich irgendwie sehr
geil dass ihr sonst ein see ist einfach
so man könnte sich wie ich mir das
vorstelle
hier soll haus rein zimmern was hier auf
der einen seite oft mit einem gang hier
halt zu dem see und jeder noch mal zu
anderen seite mit einem fetten fenster
zu dieser seite also versteht was ich
meine
also hier den fenstern bahnfans und da
drinnen haus also wenn das einer von ich
mache dann wäre das echt killer wird
bestimmt sehr toll aus ihr wolltet ihr
auch mal wieder ein passiv mit einem
besseren landschaft kann man übrigens
auch noch die sachen hier ist ein
perfekt gerade linie kann man auch die
sachen abholen einfach und sich dann
hier eine farm hinbauen oder so sehr
schön und wir dann halt noch so ein paar
andere gebirgs arten also hier haben wir
ein kleines loch einfach drin da unten
haben eine höhle weiter kann ja mal ganz
kurz hinfliegen drittel also hier und
dessen höhe darin könnt ihr auch so ein
bisschen erkunden
so nicht heraus hier und allgemeinheit
hier so ein paar kratzer landschaften
hier kann ich glaube ich auch durch
fliegen kann ich kann ich kann ich nicht
schade kann ich hier irgendwo durch ja
genau hier kann nicht durch kann man sie
durchfliegen also ersetzen das sieht
alles extrem geil aus hinternah ja da
unten ist auch noch also das ist einfach
ein stumpfes extreme hits wie möglich
findet die kompletten anordnung damit
den ganzen löchern drin und so
kann sie können sich schon sehen lassen
so dass ein paar schafe drauf ich schaue
mich grad immer irgendwo eine pyramide
ist oder irgend sowas ist allerdings
nicht der fall hier nochmal der street
kurz eingeblendet können ja verrat
schreiben steht allerdings auch im meer
oder unten in der beschreibung
und ja also das ist meine welt feucht
was ist das ist einfach so stein habe
ich auch noch nicht gesehen einfach im
dschungel so stein
das ist eine höhle absolut okay also ich
finde vor allem wenn man sieht wo krasse
landschaft schlängelt sich durch den
dschungel an sieht man also kasse
landschaften also ich finde es auf jeden
fall ganz cool den zieht weil ihr auch
mal wieder ein paar landschaft zieht
volt wollte und ich kann das gerade
nicht mit shader aufnehmen weißes 1.5
also es ist ein frischer 1.5 und naja
also je wenn es euch gefallen hat dürft
ihr gerne einen daumen hoch geben damit
ich weiteres tief vorstellung und mache
könnt ihr auch mehr einfach in die
comments in die kommentare schreiben
und wie ihr diese welt findet weil ich
finds auf jeden fall sehr sehr episch
übrigens was ja nicht gezeigt hier oben
das auch so eine kleine ablage gruppen
kaum noch etwas drauf zimmern oder so
finde ich sie auf jeden fall sehr sehr
gelassen dann würde ich einfach sagen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal tschüss